who is more afraid of commitment in
modern dating men or women
women
they're afraid of getting hurt the
pattern of the pattern that we have
created for ourselves ultimately right
dealing with situationships things of
that sort
it one if you've been dealing with a
counterfeit so long how do you recognize
the real right and so we're afraid to
get ourselves emotionally involved and
become vulnerable and intimate with
someone because we don't know if it's
the real deal because we don't know and
we've never been taught how to identify
what the real is so we're afraid because
like they say when men are ready men are
ready period they're committing but now
you look out and there's nothing to
commit to
do you think women really can't tell the
difference between a guy who's going to
settle down and a guy who won't agree or
yeah
in this day and age especially when a
lot of the guys tell the girls up front
like she said I'm just curious out of
the guys just really quick when you guys
were in whole phase of Life did you tell
the girls absolutely I was 100 honest
this is where I'm at in life but they
always try to change you would they get
mad later
[Music]
but I agree I would I I struggle with
the term counterfeit because that
assumes that a man is presenting himself
as a husband candidate or relationship
ready I think oftentimes we see what we
want to see and we blow past what they
say and we end up hurting ourselves but
blaming it on the men
do you think that's true or false I
think that's true I was thinking in
terms of counterfeit relationships not
the men being counterfeits right they've
dealt with so many situationships and
things like that they don't know what a
real relationship looks like right so
even when a guy they have trust issues
right wait so what do you mean they
don't know what a real relationship
looks like they've never seen a real
relationship
precisely issues daddy issues trust
issues and to Camille's Point all of her
friends right she's she'll have a real
conversation with them and then two
weeks later they're talking back to the
same guy why because you know what it's
about why do you keep availing yourself
to that process why do we keep going in
these circular motions because we're
comfortable it's comfort with being hurt
right it takes something it takes some
level of vulnerability trust healing to
make ourselves available for something
new and different and because we're
unfamiliar with what that new is going
to be sometimes we're too afraid to open
ourselves up to that to explore I think
we know we just don't want what we
really should have I I think we want to
force what we want on someone else when
if we're just supposed to be in a
regular relationship we have a hard time
accepting that I think that's more of of
what it is I just I disagree that it's
um well who do you want like Prince
Charming or something I think ever every
girl does I mean that's how we're
socialized but I think the problem is
like you all said we all grew up before
the internet we were able to look at Pop
Culture entertainment and say oh that's
a great show show and it ended there I
never in my wildest dreams expected that
I would be driving a luxury car in my
20s or having elaborate dates like that
was not the real world but somehow the
lines have been blurred because of
culture because of moms because of
whatever and now we think what we see
out there is what we're supposed to be
living over here and 100 I don't think
women modern women today want Prince
Charming who do they want they want
Superman
they want they want they want to take
Superman and make them Clark Kent
but they just don't want Clark Kent they
want to tame Superman they want to tame
the alpha they want the alpha to want
them and only them in a monogamous
relationship and they don't want Prince
Charming off of deck I go over my
channel time and time again
good guys nice guys
petalizing them being simps giving them
the world and then they get sh upon they
don't want Prince Charming they want
Superman to convert him into Clark Kent
and then how often does it happen
foreign Russell Wilson There You Go
Sierra's prayer meanwhile she's still up
in the Oscars half-assed naked that's
right the nerve of you Sierra grow up
you're a mother times two let's say
Savannah James look like we should be
talking about Savannah James way more
than Seattle Savannah James was the
standard on that Oscar's red carpet she
owned it it was hers she looked like a
bride all over again and I'm so proud of
her and I love her and I think she is
every woman needs to be following her
because she she's the epitome of
femininity and a wife and just being
quiet and but but but just
powerful it just seeing her I showed my
daughters her and I just said when I
compared her to all the other women that
was on the red carpet and my daughters
are just like they themselves I said
what do you think they said Savannah
James just looks like
I mean like a queen like like just like
they they were just like is she getting
married again like like are they
renewing their vows because she just
excellence and even how she conducts her
family she is we need to stop talking
about the negativity I think so much and
focus on the women who are doing it
right because I don't think they get
enough of their flowers and women like
that who are really doing what they
should do but shout out to Savannah
James I just have to say if you guys
haven't seen her she just looks go to
her Instagram follow her if you can for
those that don't know Savannah James
LeBron James's wife she so she came up
to the Oscars with a crazy looking yeah
no crumbs no crumbs in contrast to
Russell Wilson's wife Sierra so here's
the thing and I got to do a better job
of this on my channel as well as to
continue to promote the Savannah James
continue to avoid uh uh uh promote women
such as like Alicia Keys continue to
promote women that I think would be a
fantastic example of how to demonstrate
yourself out in the public we give way
too much Credence and relevance to the
ones that they don't look they don't
clean or the ones that promote this
independent lifestyle what's so crazy is
is that if you look back to like Beyonce
who's creating Independent Women at the
same time of being married to Jay-Z
these famous women don't care about
y'all they appropriated being strong and
independent for the dollar and y'all
don't hold them accountable but y'all
hold us accountable
[Music]
accountable Yahoo Melanie accountable
Yahoo accountable you hold Maggie The
Substitute Teacher accountable that's
who y'all hold accountable but not the
ones that lie to y'all it makes
fundamentally no sense to me it but at
the same time modern women don't hold
modern women accountable
competition
who do you think is more afraid of
commitment men or women
personally I think women women
I think
it's a strange one because both sides
can be scared of commitment but I think
in the past women wanted to be more
committed speaking to my grandparents
great grandparents they always talked
about growing up how important it was
that they found a man go dancing with
them marry them settle down have kids
but these days now I think women are too
scared
for commitment because they want to be
independent and be their own boss their
own future and I don't think I think
they always get maybe too scared to rely
on a man's money these days
what what do you think who's more afraid
of commitment men or women
I think men
if you want to Define commitment as
marriage
I think men making rational decisions uh
regarding long-term commitment should be
doing so and understanding the potential
negative repercussions for choosing
incorrect if you choose the incorrect
women that'll be one of the worst
decisions that you ever make in your
life why because men feel the brunt of
making an in correct decision if you
decide on a woman who
wants the false alligate
you suffer the consequences there's no
such thing as false allegations when it
comes to man on woman
if you decide to wake up on your head
every single day and you look to the
right of you and on your pillow is a
terrorist that makes your life a living
hell you're still guilty until proven
innocent
I think at the end of the day in
understanding the negative repercussions
in the family court system
and understanding what is going to
happen to you if you're the breadwinner
with alimony
with the child
managers making rational decisions
regarding commitment but at the same
time men today have so many other
options within that and this is the
scary thing if you look in a culture
such as Japan which has a rapidly
decreasing birth rate
in the level of technology that a Japan
has actually is more than the United
States you could be in a elevator five
floors down in a parking deck and still
get cell phone reception in Japan
but they utilize technology to the point
where
you can be in Japan and they have hug
parlors hmm
because men might need affection and a
[__] just go get a hug
to say that that will not be a reality
within our modern culture today within
America within North America within
Western cultures is not far outside the
reality and I think that's something
that has to be assessed they can buy
used panties out of a vending machine
in Japan yes use panties out of a
vending machine and they also uh is the
love dolls are the they are they are
innovating in terms of uh robotic
companionship but listen I always want
to finish the point real quick as well
if you look towards all of the forms of
entertainment that young men within
modern society today within Western
society today have they're coming up to
a real fundamental decision like bump
commitment marriage
let's just talk about dating if the
option is yo I can go over here and go
and see a Call of Duty LAN party with me
and my partners for the rest of this
Friday night and have a bang up time
shooting terrorists in the head versus
going on a date with a modern woman
today these men are making rational
decisions there are men that are making
rational decisions of should I stay in
tonight
beat off to the hub
instead of going out and deal with the
mouth of a modern woman like legit
they're making these rational decisions
and the technology today is bringing us
farther apart than closer together and
the thing is is like that's the point of
social media supposed to bring you
closer together but it's it's a foe it's
a far bringing closer together it's not
a closer together in reality and in fact
it's bringing us farther apart because
we have all of these short-term dopamine
driven
options
what do you think Melanie who's more
afraid of commitment men or women I
think man I think he's correct in terms
of who you want to talk about marriage
but if you want to talk about I I think
it's twofold I think if we're talking
about marriage it's going to be men just
because of the consequences that if it
doesn't work out and the responsibility
what it means to a man there's men and
they have very little benefits to being
married uh women have most of the
benefits to being married but I will say
this in terms of just like commitment
relationships women have more options in
terms of swiping right and they always
the hypergamy and and any they always
want something better something
something better can come along there
why would I do I want to settle with him
because uh oh who just popped in my DM
um it's it's actually
um you know and they will they they
don't want to tie themselves down
because somebody richer finer or
something will come along because it's
easier for us to just you know even
unless you're like a high level and
famous and people women Know Who You Are
are you're not flooded with DMS and
women coming after you but women even if
you're an average woman there's more men
trying to come at you and you never know
who could be around the corner and and
even the dating apps show this this is
why women just will constantly swipe
left on the majority of men that are out
there and this is supported by the data
as well it was a it was a um report that
recently came out that said that between
the ages of 18 to 30 women report being
in a in a relationship 60-ish percent of
the time meanwhile men in the same age
range Report with being in a
relationship 30 of the time
right so then the idea is is that most
women are dating older because it's not
within that specific age range or
lgbtq hey right so if 20ish year old men
are going their own way
then this is something that has to be
looked at because our birth rate right
now in America is the lowest that has
been in like 40 years and we're catching
up to Japan
so we have to address these issues today
because if not you don't want to be in a
country with a rapidly declining birth
rate that's like being in a corporation
with a rapidly declining profit margin
but you don't want to be a part of that
we have to understand that those guys uh
you know those guys are actually you you
said that opting for uh video games also
opting to actually lead the country
against possible Bros as many of you
know you know I was just banned
talk
advertised on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible